being a man is hard and requires you to
have certain skills college didn't
expect you to know all of these skills
but the world sure as hell does
oh you did not you did like laughing at
your boss's joke keep your gaze fixed
firmly on your co-workers elbow in order
to avoid poor contact then slap that
hand like it insulted your mother apply
in moderation one dab behind each year
easy broseph sorry I got excited Reed
clumps of words instead of one word at a
time
and don't sound the words out in your
head just what are you doing it's hard I
don't like this what was all that
college for I was an art major okay look
I made a doodle shave magnesium onto a
wood pyramid and ignite it by striking a
spark on the Flint rod if you fail at
this then feel free to use lighter fluid
like a big idiot
and emotionally-charged outburst can
fool the most zealous sports fan into
believing you understand the game that
is messed up
that was a poor outcome to a fun game
that guy just made some bros for life
smell where the melon was cut from its
stem much like an infant if it smells
good then it is good shake the melon and
listen for the rattle of seeds if you
can hear the seeds it's ready to eat
wait I didn't hear any seed that's bad
right narrator gasp sorry man I can't
help you dude most importantly a man
knows how to make a drink and you're no
longer a bro man you're a man bro and
man is it good